on
c'est un intime de françois hollande que
nous recevons cette semaine à preuve par
3 bernard poignant bonsoir bonsoir et
merci d'être là conseillé un peu
spéciale on peut le dire tout de suite
vous avez un bureau à l'élysée bien sûr
vous avez l'oreille du chef de l'état
mais vous n'apparaissez pas dans
l'organigramme de l'elysée et vous aurez
l'occasion d'expliquer votre rôle exact
tout à l'heure à perrine tarneaud et
vous répondrais également aux questions
de karine perret de l' agence
france-presse
bien sûr cette semaine comme toutes les
semaines notre partenaire pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat notre
partenaire avec également dailymotion
c'est la première fois dans un poignant
que françois hollande se voit créditer
d'un sans faute depuis son élection la
gestion des tragédies qui ont endeuillé
la france est réveillé les peurs a été
saluée par tous un par la droite par la
gauche les sondages s'envole avec un
bond de plus de 20 points 10 l'un est il
enfin devenu président par l'épreuve
je pense pour moi il l'est depuis le
début mais les événements ont révélé sa
personnalité je pense davantage aux
français dès le mercredi
pas simplement dimanche dès le mercredi
quand ils essaieront du tout de suite
sur les lieux
montrant son empathie et sa compassion
et en même temps le soir même en
s'adressant aux français
donc dans la même journée il était le
holland que je connais dans l'empathie
proche des proches de la douleur et
l'intimité donc ça ce sont des traits de
caractère et le soir l'attend aussi sur
b et l'on l'attendait sur des décisions
aussi elles sont venues mais le soir
s'il est dans la gravité et
souvenez-vous du taux d'audience il a
été écoutée par près de 22 millions de
téléspectateurs alors que quelques jours
auparavant ses voeux ne l'avait été que
par moins de 10 c'est à dire que tout
d'un coup les français se sont tournés
vers lui parce que il incarne la france
dont la durée d'un quinquennat
elle attendait de lui et des décisions
et la conduite
malheureusement d'une opération pour à
la suite de cet acte barbare donc il
s'est révélé la aux yeux des français
ou plutôt les français en se sont
tournés vers lui puisque bilingue sur la
fonction régalienne suprême exactement
que vous soyez populaire ou impopulaires
et que la politique que vous menez soit
jugée bonne ou pas bonne
dans ces moments-là il est l'incarnation
même de la nation de la france et de la
république en ce qui nous concerne il a
eu des mérites particulier quand même
non ada ensuite mercredi jeudi vendredi
samedi dimanche
mais dès mercredi je pense qu'il a posés
là le les actes qu'il fallait est-ce que
vous même vous avez changé votre regard
sur françois hollande non non non parce
que je sais que c'est quelqu'un qui est
capable d'un extrême sang froid en même
temps d'une extrême compassion qui s'est
décidé dans les moments graves comme
celui là qui peut prendre dans d'autres
moments son temps pour décider
ce n'est pas un brutal dans la vie
politique intérieure
il n'a pas à décider forcément
rapidement et brutalement sur tout sujet
donc parfois on dit de lui qu'il est
hésitant qui sinon je n'ai jamais
regardé comme ça il n'est pas brutal
il n'est pas brutal donc il peut prendre
du temps écouter et ensuite décider mais
là dans les moments graves et autant que
je sais c'est le trancher là je
n'appartiens pas bien sûr or aux
réunions de crise ou encore moins bien
sûr au conseil de défense et parfois
vous vous le voyez sans le voyez entre
cela je ressente gelé senti extrêmement
concentré tendu et tranchant donc à vous
écouter gêné il ce n'est que justice
donc ils bénéficient aujourd'hui de deux
estime et de respect j'ai trouvé d'abord
que pendant deux ans il a été très
souvent massacrés par les uns et par les
autres donc le le fameux hollande
machine est en sang des donnés à coeur
joie et
ça a forcément marqué les français mais
et ça nous attriste est les uns et les
autres bien sûr qui le connaissons et
qui ont une proximité plus ou moins
grande
avec lui j'ai même été affectés ont dit
qu il s'est exercé enfin qu'il sait se
montrer indifférent
alors c'est en même temps pour le voir
et le connaître depuis longtemps c'est
quelqu'un qui ne se plaint jamais qui
n'a pas de peur physique qui est très
courageux très robuste et qui est
capable de faire face à mon avis à
toutes les situations et qu'on le
croyait donc pendant deux ans le langue
bashing oui il a fait face et je pense
non moi je n'ai jamais entendu se
plaindre qu'après deux mois j'ai
toujours vu régulier continuant sa tâche
mais je me suis toujours dit bon sang
qu'est-ce qu'il en prend dans la figure
le pouvoir de l'indifférence comme
talents comme disait françois mitterrand
mitterrand avait mis le sait ça puisque
nous en avons parlé mais il se souvient
bien de cet entretien
elkabbach qui a été diffusée après sa
mort selon l'accord qu'il avait avec
jean pierre elkabbach et c'est le
dernier mot quand el kabbaj lui demande
quelle est la qualité suprême pour
exercer cette fonction
terrible réponse de françois mitterrand
il dit après deux secondes de silence
l'indifférence alors c'est pas une
réponse qui me convient je sais pas si
elle convient à françois hollande
mais quand on est dans la fonction
présidentielle où il faut faire du cuir
mais la différence aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui allons il est pas hélas ne
l'était pas il a même été le mais le
mercredi soir de l'attentât jean-pierre
jouyet a réuni les commandes du cabinet
présent et pour nous parler un peu de la
journée de la suite et il nous a dit que
le président était très affecté mais
toucher vraie soirée
vous avez dit en même temps il a fait
face veulent utiliser ou même temps que
l'expression de hollande bashing quake
sophie nina de alors
luc mélenchon arnaud montebourg en
passant par nicolas sarkozy en tous les
cas selon les propos qui lui avaient je
sais pas si c'est fini en tout cas
critiques ne sont pas réduits au silence
est contenue dans la personnalité non
non ça il ya des choses qui revient en
haut pour moi il ya trois procès qui
devrait cesser 3,3 procès pour le procès
en légitimité de la gauche a dirigé la
france parce qu'il a été fait quand même
puisque ce pas nathalie kosciusko
morizet je me souviens disant que la
gauche a gagné par effraction donc elle
a gagné par l'élection
ce qui n'est pas pareil et puis le
procès en capacité de françois hollande
a présidé la france ce procès lui a été
fait sans arrêt et compris par son
prédécesseur n'a pour essayer de danse
appellée les bases de sa personnalité et
même le procès en légèreté
gouvernementales et en amateur il
souvenez vous ça a été fait à de
nombreuses reprises et je pense que
c'est trois procès là en légitimité pour
la gauche en capacité pour le président
et on légèreté pour le gouvernement
elles sont à remiser au magasin des
souvenirs à bien d'autres encore du
procès alors peut-être par les plus
écoutées l'absence de résultats
économiques la france et ce en cale
sèche mais niant tout au long de l'année
mois après mois on va encore voir le
chômage s'est aggravé
alors j'espère que non que ça ne se dit
l'année c'est ce que disent ils et
colère et j'espère qu'ils seront des
prévisions que le 104 1000 chômeurs de
plus qu en métropole 10 l'unedic c'est
ce qu'ils disent c'est exactement une
énigme alors les les événements qui se
sont passés ne vont pas à mener
le président à mon avis je peux être
démontée a changé son cap économique
parce qu'il croit beaucoup à la
politique qu'il a qui l'a engagé avec
les 50 milliards de réduction de
dépenses publiques et les 40 milliards
d' aides aux entreprises mais vraiment
plus fort et plus ferme ce sont ses mots
d'ailleurs je crois il dit qu'il se sent
plus fort et plus fort est-ce que ça le
rend aujourd'hui parce qu'il vous dit de
vos échanges plus fort plus ferme pour
imposer ce cap et s'est vu je pense que
oui je pense qu'il est ce à l'heure
alors je peux faire de transposition
j'allais vivre entre eux ce qui s'est
passé dans la semaine et 7 et 8 9
janvier et la politique est bien sûr
néanmoins au sial je pense que la
personnalité lui même est forcément
conforté alors il va continuer sur son
axe il va pas en changer les lois qui
sont en cours vont être
votez débattu d'abord puis voté puis
promulgué le cap économique a été fixée
il faut simplement que ça donne quelques
résultats l effectif vous avez raison m
le vrai résultat aux yeux des français
sera mesuré quand le nombre des chômeurs
de la catégorie à c'est à dire ceux qui
sont l'expression n'est peut-être pas
bonne pleinement au chômage quand celle
là commencera à diminuer alors j'espère
qu'on le verra je peux pas pronostiqueur
bien sûr dans l'année 2015 et à ce
moment là et à mon avis d'ailleurs si ça
commence à baisser à décroître
les français ne le croiront pas tout de
suite ils auront des doutes
donc il faut plusieurs mois et françois
hollande eux se l'imaginent considère
que c'est possible à partir de l'année
2000 type d'accord car le dit d'ailleurs
peut-être dans le deuxième semestre
quelqu'un et puis voyez pour connaître
pour avoir l'oeuvre entendu de quelques
industriels qui m'ont dit au moins un
grand groupe que ce qui s'est passé là
fait regarder la france dans le monde
différemment leur donne pas des marchés
des contrats les facilite quand même
parce que il y a eu certains hollande
machine mais il ya eu aussi une france
bat chine
et ça c'était très mauvais sur sur toute
la planète
et quelque part le monde a retrouvé sa
france alors j'ai parlé des sondages
tout à l'heure où les surveiller de très
près bien sûr l elysée il ya des bonds
spectaculaires dont mais ça s'est
produit sous d'autres présidences
tellement tragique pour famille grâce à
ses produits pour lui en janvier fille
marguerite rang mais la suite n'a pas
été bonnes donc venir attention j'ai
envie de dire attention attention aux à
la grande illusion
alors je sais si celle de comparaison
parce que j'ai vécu l'autre période
françois mitterrand après ces sondages
très florissant change michel rocard
s'est pas compris sa part les français
en même temps très peu de mois après le
parti socialiste est
englué dans les affaires bon on va pas
refaire l'histoire mais on sait que tout
ça vienne référence ses rebonds sont
fragiles wii peuvent ainsi que des
guerres les attentats mais je pense que
ça diminuera pas ça ne reviendra pas et
ne reviendra pas comme avant donc pour
dire non à je suis pas je suis pas
prophète c'est pas prophète c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est un souhait que je bien
sûr vous allez quand même vous
interroger sur 2017
bernard poignant est ce que vous pensez
que après ce qui s'est passé parce que
vous dites ça ne reviendra pas comme
avant l'image du chef de l'état est ce
que certains pourraient encore
aujourd'hui et demain envisager une
autre candidature socialiste pour 2017
voire la nécessité pour françois
hollande de passer par une primaire
alors pour moi la primaire je l'espère
en tout cas et aux socialistes qui pense
je le redis enterrés là si le président
sortant
c'est lui qui décidera c'est pas moi
mais si ces juges jeudi quand même mon
souhait si les s'il est candidat au
renouvellement de son mandat il faut
s'en tenir là d'accord selon l'adage de
raffarin que j'aime bien
il n'y a pas de concurrent dans le camp
du président donc s'il est candidat
c'est lui qui va le décider
je crois qu'il faut s'en tenir là je
vois mal le président de la république
en fonction
soumis à des primaires donc à une double
élection ait le risque en plus d'un
dérapage de primaire ou d'un score moyen
au médium non le président sortant s'il
est candidat
eh bien il faut tous derrière lui ça va
être un paradoxe pour le parti
socialiste parce qu'en 2011 on a fait
des primaires qui ne sont pas dans nos
statuts et on n'en ferait pas alors
qu'elles sont dans nos statuts mais je
crois qu'il faut avoir une capacité
d'adaptation à la situation à lui voilà
la réponse en tous les cas à cette
perspective le sénat vote c'est vous que
vous exprimez la dont nous n'avions ce
soir votre réponse en tous les cas
attiré mans dont le ministre du
gouvernement qui avait dit qu'il fallait
absolument passer par une primaire il
l'a dit à votre place il ya quelques
semaines une question je pense qu'il a
changé d'avis il a changé d'avis à bwin
je pensais pas intelligent dont qui la
fera changer d'avis un mot sur les
autres responsables politiques et
notamment marine le pen comme est-ce que
vous avez jugé son attitude ces
dernières semaines et pensez vous comme
le président du sénat gérard larcher
qu'elle a peut-être perdu la chance de
se qualifier pour le second tour de la
prochaine présidentielle havre je pense
que j'ai entendu gérard larcher de dire
ça il faut être très prudent sur les
résultats d'une élection mais je pense
que malgré la polémique du samedi
je crois que sont sa place auraient été
au milieu de tous les français elle a
sans doute raté quelque chose
le président comme le premier ministre
ont dit comme le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste vient qui veut bien
qu'il veut et donc pour 2017 ça reste un
pays petit
attendez on verra les élections on verra
on verra encore félicité jean-pierre
raffarin il est à votre place la semaine
dernière il a estimé que le trésor de
l'union nationale était dans les mains
de françois hollande et que c'était à
lui d'agir il est conscient de cela le
chef de l'état oui mais qu'est ce qu'on
entend par union nationale s'est passé
c'est pas un gouvernement rassemblant
tous les partis je pense qu'aujourd'hui
c'est plus un état d'esprit qu'il faut
garder l'assemblée nationale ne change
pas de configuration les débats
économiques sociaux sociétaux fiscaux
énergétique
ils reprennent leur l'endroit après tout
quand on quand on sort de redevenir
comme avant aux jeux pan moi j'espère en
tout cas que l'état d'esprit change
d'agréer dire que la hiérarchie des
apportant ses des urgences soit plus
relativiser alors on va voir si c'est
l'état d'esprit du côté du parti
socialiste où on sait que le cap que
vous avez réaffirmer le cap de françois
hollande est contestée par certains les
frondeurs karine perret de l' agence
france-presse
va nous rejoindre dans un instant mais
voyons d'abord sur ce thème le reportage
de marie brémaud existe-t-il un devoir
de silence une obligation à l'accalmie
au vu des événements tragiques des
semaines passées pour ceux au sein de la
majorité qui n'ont jamais ménagé le
président de la république et l'exécutif
pas question de se coucher
ce qui est important
c'est d'abord que les terroristes ne
change pas les habitudes démocratique de
ce pays
on n'est pas dans un état de siège etc
il faut que la vie comme des
représentants la république l'a dit
reprenne ses droits et on recommence
comme avant
l'expression sera peut-être atténuer
l'expression des différences mais le
débat de fond reste et à gauche de la
gauche la cible de toutes les attaques
c'est la future loi macron je considère
que la loi macron représente un certain
nombre de régression sociale et c'est
pas parce qu'il ya eu un événement d'une
telle ampleur que je me priverais de
dire oui mais pour d'autres et la donne
a bel et bien changé et certains
frondeurs pourrait faire preuve de plus
de retenue dans leur opposition au
gouvernement s'il y a deux semaines une
soixantaine de députés auraient pu voter
contre le projet de loi macron il ne
serait plus qu'une trentaine aujourd'hui
un effet collatéral de l'après 11
janvier sur lequel compte matignon mais
les irréductibles poil à gratter la
république ne sont pas prêts à se
laisser bâillonner
moi j'espère que ceux qui sont contre
parce qu'ils ont vraiment des arguments
et que le centre votre contre et que
ceux qui sont courts parce qu'on leur a
dit qu'il fallait voter pour réfléchisse
à deux fois
ça ne fera pas une majorité s'asséchant
on dit souvent il faut que nous soyons
solidaires de l'exécutif c'est vrai mais
c'est bien aussi contre l'exécutif et
solidaire sa majorité et de son
électorat
réponse le 26 janvier avec le début de
l'examen de la loi macron où l'on verra
si la politique reprend le dessus
n'a jamais participé à une émission
politique celle-ci vanger non 45 minutes
depuis que vous êtes aussi une ambiance
oui on en prend plein question car oui
oui donc vous venez de dire j'espère que
l'état d'esprit va changer est ce que
vous pensez que ça peut perdurer dans le
domaine politique
je l'espère en tout cas j'écoutais votre
reportage avant de parler d'union
nationale il faut parler d'union
socialiste voyez vous c'est déjà pas mal
ça entendu aujourd'hui les frondeurs
dire que la loi macron à l'état n'était
pas votable donc la politique reprend
ses droits ont petit à petit oui
forcément
mais moi je souhaite qu'ils
réfléchissent à leur vote final ce que
dans la loi il ya beaucoup de choses
hein il ya 106 article de mémoire il ya
plein de sujets abordés donc on peut
être hostile ou en désaccord ou en
moitié en accord avec telle ou telle
disposition bon ça ça va être le débat
parlementaire
mais après il ya le vote final donc
j'espère que pour le vote final
l'ensemble du groupe socialistes et au
delà se retrouvent je veux l'union
socialiste c'est tout le monde
un seul moteur en feu sous la halle le
vote final alors je veux bien le vote
final n'est pas la réalité
add on verra on verra ça va cheminer à
sa vache mine c'est aussi qu'ils seront
moins nombreux à voter contre par
rapport à ce dont je le sens je le
souhaite parce que c'est une loi où il
ya qui traite beaucoup de sujets donc à
partir de ce moment là vous pouvez à
être
réservé voire hostile avec tel sujet et
on prendre prétexte pour voter pour la
contre la loi toute entière c'est ça
d'une difficulté
c'est une loi ça touche un mille sujets
enfin j'veux pas 1000 mètres des
dizaines de sujets donc j'espère que les
socialistes qui sont pas d'accord ou
réservés sur tel ou tel sujet mais qui
peuvent l'être sur beaucoup d'autres et
bien dans le vol final qui sera quelque
part un vote qui est d'accord avec
l'ensemble du gouvernement se retrouve
même si dans le débat parlementaire vous
avez plus de nuances après tout il ya
des amendements il ya ceux ci à cela
vous pouvez re les amendements qui passe
d'autres qui passent pas mais en finale
jeu lorsque la la première lecture sera
terminée je souhaite vraiment qu'il y
ait union socialiste à l'assemblée
nationale
et après au sénat et de la sorte est ce
que vous pensez que pour leur rendez
vous du congrès socialiste au mois de
juin
les débats seront vu l'état d'esprit le
contexte un peu minorés un peu étouffé
jeu alors c'est pareil je le pense
autant que je le souhaite parce que il y
avait des jeux santons sentait pointe de
sujets en fait dans le dans ce congrès
l'émotion d'orientation seront arrêté le
11 avril après les élections
départementales donc ça serait quand
même bien en connaître le résultat
et il ya deux sujets qui seront
sensibles quelle orientation sort du
congrès et faut-il ou non des primaires
si avec le président sortant
sur les primaires je pense que on va
assister à l'enterrement de cette
affaire pour dès lors que le président
sortant est candidat avec jean tanguy
l'hypothèse inverse non mais quel crédit
lui qui desservaient moi je souhaite
avait déjà annoncé je sais rien du tout
moi je souhaite qu'ils au soir par les
forces aimant du rendez vous 2010 est
pour lui oui mike donc pour les pour les
primaires si le président sortant et
candidat tout le monde derrière soumet
pas aux primaires donc je pense que ça
dans le congrès ça devrait est évacué
enfin pour moi il faut l'évacuer et
deuxièmement il ya l'orientation ça
c'est autre chose il faut que la motion
d'orientation soit pas les petit doigt
sur la couture du pantalon de ce que
fait le gouvernement mais soit en
harmonie avec ce que fait le président
et le gouvernement parce que s'il y
avait une distorsion grave entre
l'orientation du parti socialiste ce que
l'on appelle dans notre jargon la motion
finale
la motion ultime là ce serait non
seulement 9 pour l'exécution serait
probable quoi que ce soit un congrès
anti hollande
non il faut aussi que lens à vos balais
laisser ben oui mais c'est la motion
finale c'est la finale qui compte pour
moi
quelle est la majorité du parti
socialiste oui mais qui ensuite volé
dessus jean christophe cambadélis il est
d'accord séduction mais hélas c'est lui
qui est à la même place prendront les
frondeurs l'ale gauche benoit mais vous
savez vous que vous connaissez nos
règles
du parti socialiste c'est assez simple
vous avez le droit selon les règles de
déposer une motion le 11 avril qui est
soumis au vote le 21 mai c'est ça la
règle
donc n'importe qui peut enfin pas
n'importe qui il ya quelques obligations
à respecter peut présenter une motion
mais voilà elle est soumis au vote de
nos adhérents et ce qui compte c'est le
vote des adhérents et donc j'espère que
ce vote là s'oriente vers là où
l'émotion qui seront en harmonie avec la
politique du président et du
gouvernement et ensuite à une fois qu'on
a fait ça on se retrouve dans notre
congrès et puis il ya les
les accords les alliances etc il ya un
texte qui sort majoritairement et c'est
celui-là qui doit être en harmonie avec
leur président ville c'est ça le congrès
socialiste a c'est une machinerie
compliqué d'abord nous les socialistes
on est parfois compliqué ça je reconnais
elle est donc vous avez tout un
cheminement j'avais droit de vous
permettre d'être compliqué quand vous
avez le pouvoir en bas compass compliqué
pour décider mais on peut être plus
subtil pour réfléchir oui bien sûr et ça
commence le 7 février le 7 février vous
avez des contributions aux
téléspectateurs peuvent trouver ça un
peu un peu et on va pas être un peu
minorés par cet état d'esprit lancé un
appel à l'union socialiste à moi je suis
pour l'union socialiste d'abord et
l'union de la gauche ensuite très simple
j'ai j'ai été élevé même si j'étais
rocardien dans mon parcours
politiquement j'ai été élevé par
françois mitterrand donc l'union des
socialistes elle rassemblement de la
gauche et dans un troisième challenge et
la politique la politique le cap
économique et de françois hollande
materrazi aujourd'hui ça non je crois
pas parce que je pense que la politique
savait il ya trois autres pôles il n'y a
pas que je voyais ce s'il dit flo dire
et il n'y a pas qu'une seule politique
nous il y en a d'autres
elle a raison et il ya notamment la
politique y compris à gauche qui
consiste à laisser creuser les déficits
et augmenter la dette non françois
hollande sur ce terrain là pendant sa
campagne on l'a peut-être pas assez
écoutée sur ce sujet a été extrêmement
clair si je suis élue je ne veux pas
creuser les déficits je veux les réduire
c'est très long à faire et je ne veux
pas augmenter la dette même si elles
augmentent quand même je veux moi je
veut freiner le tout c'est un paquebot
la france 1
son budget vous le changez pas d'un coup
de baguette magique mais le coup de
frein et 50 milliards de dépenses en moi
c'est pas rien je vous rappelle que
l'ump dans son simple du dos dans sa
convention du 25 janvier qui est
toujours en vigueur
s'en vante pas d'ailleurs ses 130
milliards sur cinq ans 130 sur cinq ans
l'année 2015 est une année de rendez
vous électoraux vous qui êtes qui
prenait le pouls sur le terrain comment
est ce que vous ressentez les choses
justement après ces événements est ce
que le front national peut gagner
je sais pas je deviens chiffres au
hasard 10 points de plus où est ce que
on peut s'attendre à ce que peut-être
l'électorat de gauche qui s'étaient
fortement abstenus lors des dernières
élections se remobilise comment vous
voyez les choses on va avoir une sorte
de premier test le 1er février avec
l'élection de radoub dans la législative
là je souhaite vraiment parce qu'il y
avait des craintes étaient écrits dit
par les commentateurs que le candidat
socialiste ne parviendrait pas forcément
au second tour s'était dit un frédéric
barbier il faut que ce candidat soit
bhutto à jeudi il faut ces électeurs qui
vont décider mais j'espère que ce qui
s'est passé là va avoir un effet et
compris sur cette élection qui est une
une fusion partielle d'une fierté
retrouvée bien leur a pris
vous avez tout à fait raison je les
récentes y part des candidats aux
cantonales dans mon département tout
simplement qu'elle finistère quelques
parcelles et ces derniers temps c'était
pas forcément facile d'être candidat
socialiste à des élections et tout d'un
coup
pour ceux que j'ai vus avant noël et me
le disait il n'est pas pas évident
d'aller chez les gens ça n'est pas
toujours bien reçus et là par contre
tout d'un coup vous avez une fierté des
candidats fierté leur président
fierté leur gouvernance des électeurs
qui compte aussi oui d'accord mais
admettez quand même que quand vous êtes
encore par des bus c'est que c'est ça ça
vous donne une force par une amie kim
cattrall est évidemment alors après vous
savez les vois ça se trient pas ça se
compte et donc à partir du moment où ben
là vous voyez il ya ce que ce que ça
donne en finale mais vous n'êtes plus à
même de défendre ce que fait votre
président est ce que fait votre
gouvernement est folle et là je pense
que légalement je vois les choses comme
nous également oui on tombait
l'accompagnait ça y est ils sont en
campagne certains avant noël déjà ils
sont content et je pense la même chose
pour les régionales en tout cas bon
c'est vrai que la gauche a beaucoup de
départements alors dirige beaucoup de
conseils généraux dirige presque toutes
les conseils régionaux donc c'est sûr
que ça va être difficile d'en gagner
plus ça je reconnais est ce que c'est
possible d'éviter la débâcle
oui j'espère même que 20 mois je cite je
pense que dans quelles proportions a je
donne jamais de proportions moi je
considère qu' on doit garder tout ce
qu'on a et on gagnait plus jamais et je
sais que vous est ce que ce sera pas la
raclée non voilà des bacs pas la raclée
l'âme avec catégorique je suis catégorie
je devais vous l'êtes jeu de vous je
devrais pas l'être parce qu'il va la
voulez vous avoir fait temps d'élection
je sais ça lui même été catégoriques de
gassco geris voulu éviter la déroute
parce que je trouve que nos candidats et
nos électeurs le socle socialiste je lis
entendu dans la
qu'ils viennent moi même où j'ai perdu
l'élection je lai gelé bien entendu
c'est comme si savoureux a redonné du
tonus il voulait on a vécu un drame
terrible une barbarie fonds considérable
d'accords une réaction apprécié juste du
président et l'éxécutif
et puis cette foule qui est venue les
chefs d'état
tout d'un coup une front national selon
vous ne valez on va voir ça je sais pas
je suis très prudent je sais pas comment
l'électorat va sans doute qu'il a sonné
électorale à lui le front national est
ce qui va baisser pas baissé je ne sais
pas mais la france s'est retrouvée le
monde a retrouvé sa france que voulez
vous ça ça booste ça donne du tonus et
même dans le monde économique comme
celle on dit souvent l'économie la
psychologie à la confiance et tout ça et
ça ça la donne moi j'étais moi même
extrêmement fier mais vous êtes monsieur
monsieur parti socialiste à l'elysée ce
que vous en parlez avec une fougue la
une parce que j'ai toujours pensé à je
connais moi je suis adhérent du parti
socialiste depuis 40 ans à j'en ai vécu
des hauts des bas mais je sais très bien
d'un parti qui datent de 1905 et l'un a
vécu des vertes et des pas mûres
il a fait d'excellentes choses il a eu
des délais moins bonne chose aussi mais
il est un socle permanent dans
l'histoire de la france
il restera enfin je vous interroger sur
la façon dont vous avez vos surveiller
ça un peu comme le lait sur le feu à
l'elysée
non je fais des notes à françois
hollande sur le sujet du parti
socialiste à la mairie bouchard est
arrivé parler d'accord je fais tout pas
sur le parti socialiste mais malgré ça
peut arriver ça date d'à coeur merci
ainsi karim père est injustement docteur
inferno va nous rejoindre maintenant
pour vous interroger sur votre rôle
exact auprès de françois hollande
ça c'est toujours un mystère à c'est un
mystère adversaire à la dernière partie
de l'émission va nous éclairer enfin
qu'est-ce que vous faites donc auprès de
françois hollande qui bien sûr comme
tous les présidents de la vème
république est exposée au syndrome du
château alain c'est à dire isolement
sandra cerqueira on l'appelle le
syndrome de la tour d'ivoire ce
sentiment d'isolement qui guette tous
les présidents de la république
comme ses prédécesseurs françois
hollande n'a pu l'éviter
rappelez-vous valéry giscard d'estaing
il essayer justement de recevoir des
gens divers et variés pour avoir contact
avec les français
mais jacques chirac aussi nicolas
sarkozy de même et c'est tous ont tenté
et se sont rendus compte que en réalité
la concentration du pouvoir est telle
qu'ils ne peuvent pas s'échapper de
leurs fonctions le chef de l'état dit ne
pas avoir anticipé cet isolement de
l'avoir même sous-estimé son entourage
assure qu'il en souffre françois
hollande reconnaît aujourd'hui que le
président normal n'existe pas ses amis
politiques disent l'avoir vu avec regret
tomber dans le piège de l'elysée c'est
presque malgré lui que le président
s'est enfermé dans le pouvoir françois
hollande a mis du temps à prendre toute
la dimension de sa fonction et tout ce
que tout ce qui est allé avec le fait
qu'il peut pas avoir le même rapport aux
gens aux français qui ne peut pas
répondre à toutes les questions tout le
temps qu'on lui pose dès qu'on lui tend
un micro
o gestion de son image tout un tas de
choses qui lui coûte cette journaliste
du monde a passé une semaine en
immersion à l'elysée ce qui l'a frappé
le besoin de liberté de françois
hollande
l' envie de s'échapper plus forte que
chez ses prédécesseurs il en fait il
s'autorise un peu d échappée hors
ordonné lisez le soir principalement le
soir où il se rend son média et sans
publicité s'est pas inscrit à son agenda
mais il se rend dans des endroits où il
est invité pour essayer de d'aller à la
rencontre de vrais gens entre guillemets
et pour fuir une solitude qui lui pèse
françois hollande s'est entouré d'un
proche collaborateur dont les liens
familiaux le rassure son ami de toujours
jean-pierre jouyet
on appelle ça le syndrome du repli voilà
perrine tarneaud est avec nous monsieur
poignant et accompagné françois hollande
lors de certaines de ces soirées non non
non je vous appartenait aux vrais gens
oui il l'a dit il l'a dit dans une
formule dans le
discours du bourget c'était le 22
janvier ça fait trois ans la semaine
prochaine
j'aime les gens et c'est quelqu'un qui a
besoin de ce lien là avec lille il en a
besoin
c'est à la fois politique et c'est aussi
affectif presque un peu chaque modèle
civil a besoin de partager ça avec
jacques chirac
oui exactement il jacques chirac aimait
ça mitterrand était avait une plus
grande distance
il faut de giscard il lui il avait une
méthode il invitait les éboueurs à
prendre le petit déjeuner ou sa vie
c'est chez les gens oui oui mais il
n'empêche qu'il éprouvait quand même ce
besoin là général de gaulle dans au
début de la cinquième
mon âge me permets de lui avoir serré la
main en 1959 il était au mieux il aimait
bien les foules
c'est vrai c'est vrai que ce pouvoir
quand même de l'elysée qui isole il
isole c'est à dire rien
d'abord rendez compte le nom d'
obligations d'un président sur une année
je le vois dans la cour de les effrayer
mans le nombre de chefs d'états de chefs
de gouvernement
deux ministres qui viennent dans une
année visites officielles ou visitent le
plus plus plus discrète si je puis dire
le nombre d'obligations cas le président
haut dans les conseils européens dans
les jets machin dans les chais alors le
jeu n'en perdait pas forcément mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que le vrai
contact
vous n'êtes pas tous les jours c'est
vrai sur les marchés vous pouvez pas
faire ça parce que vous êtes le conseil
les rythmes du conseil des maires je
vois bien est compris dans son agenda
vous avez des rendez vous réguliers avec
certains ministres régaliens c'est
normal donc vous êtes happé par ça et
puis l'ambiance de l'elysée fait vous
êtes pris en charge finalement y compris
pour la sécurité du président la
sécurité du président et elle est un peu
renforcé forcément avec l'est
donc pris en charge et de tout ça non
mais tous les présidents y compris sous
la troisième république certains
disaient que c'est une prison c'est
armand fallières disait c'est un bel
endroit mais y'a pas d'avancement elle
est donc vous avez vous êtes vous êtes
pris quoi dans cette affaire c'est
françois hollande qui s'échappe
d'abord il aime beaucoup sa liberté
c'est simple soirée puis vous à vous
aussi
oui mais moi si vous voulez mon rôle
d'abord je lui fait traditionnellement
des notes parce que j'aime bien faire ça
et je rends compte des des élus je fais
des déjeuners ou des dîners d'élus je
les fais en arrivant quand il est arrivé
pour des députés élus pour la première
fois pour des sénateurs je les fais pour
des prises dans le conseil généraux je
les fais pour les mères ayant perdu leur
mandat
et dieu sait si j'étais bien placé pour
la lumière y est vous consoler mais
voilà j'en ai reçu plein de 80 environ
donc ceux qui n'ont pas les publics et à
partir de là comme je reçois depuis le
mois de décembre et je continue
compris cette semaine et la semaine
prochaine des associations d'élus de
palets grandin mais associons
thématiques ou deux qui sont se
réunissent par taille de ville et puis
après je fais un compte rendu au
président ou à la caisse qui m'a est que
vous lui adressez directement directs et
indirects des satisfactions tirez vous
personnellement de ce prêt j'aime faire
ça
j'aime la vie politique ah j'aime la vie
politique et quand vous aimez la vie
pour lui mais on a envie de résultats
l'influencé alors ça alors ça vous ne
savez jamais si vous êtes influent ça
vous ne pouvez pas le savoir et surtout
pas auprès de françois hollande qui est
qui lui d'autres contacts que vous même
donc vous ne savez pas quelle est votre
part
il faut d'ailleurs de la lutte souvent
d'un fou je ne cite pas assad mais vous
ne pouvez pas il faut pas le savoir je
lui ai dit un jour le pouvoir suppose du
sacré l influence du mystère donc il
faut rester de les retrouver alors il
est fait à ses conseillers bien fait la
chance d'avoir cet axe est de retour
avec un petit mot tout ça parce que pour
quelqu'un qui est qui est auprès d'un
président d'un homme d'un ministre c'est
la même chose de d'autres fonctions mais
celle-là est suprême
c'est très important de savoir que ce
que vous lui communiquer et quand même
lui donc il faut qu'il y ait un retour
est-ce que c'est facile de garder une
franchise un ton très direct alors
vis-à-vis de d'un du chef de l'état que
vous connaissez depuis 30 ans est aussi
un ami oui alors il faut il faut vous
plus voilà quand vous écrivez moi je
fais beaucoup par écrit en réalité un
jeu fait beaucoup d'un bon pied oui
parce que c'est facile
et puis votre pensée elle est plus
ordonnée quand vous faites un écrit est
ce que ça vous permet d'être direct
d'être fou et vous pouvez la tuerie vous
demande aussi de temps en temps ben
passe donc me voir image journée vient
vraiment
non moi alors je demande un rendez vous
je l'obtiens leur demande pas beaucoup
ces gens-là peine de déranger un
président ça sert à rien mais c'est
votre ami
oui mais ça n'empêche c'est un pêche
c'est le président est-ce qu'on peut
être conseiller du président de la
république est également son ami un ami
de trente ans je pense qu'on dit souvent
c'est jean pierre jouyet oui par exemple
oui oui je pense qu'ils ont fait en tout
cas le système marche pas vous pouvez
répondre pour vous non mais j'ai en tout
cas pour le pour constater la seconde il
marchait bien aussi avec pierre rené
lemas avant mais il n'avait pas la même
relation historique que l'ancien
secrétaire général de l'elysée voilà
maintenant à laquelle j'avais avec jean
pierre jouyet jusqu'au disque amitiés
politiques cette info
il faut pas qu'il ya des exceptions de
compatibilité est ce que le conseiller
du président un public peut lui même
être évité si parce que forcément votre
fonction suscite un certain nombre de
fantasmes
on se demande un peu quel est votre
pouvoir d'influencé de manger comment
jouer non moi je joue pas parce que
c'est moi je suis pas je suis je j'ai 40
ans de vie politique d'élection ça donc
je suis pas dans une même police
position que certains autres pour
beaucoup de conseillers présidentiels ou
ministériel c'est un moment de leur vie
un moment leurs parcours professionnels
y compris donc vous pouvez pas comparer
ça à moi je ne demande rien je suis pas
membre du cabinet vous l'avez dit
puisque je n'appartiens pas à
l'organigramme
je n'ai pas de contrat de cabinet pas de
rémunération donc je fais ça françois
hollande m'a demandé quand il a été élu
qu'est ce que tu aimerais faire je dis
simplement est avec toi l'elysée mais
les gentils mais les gens qui viennent
vous
voir vos visiteurs ce qu'elle pourra
montrer ils ont tous quand même des
actions ils ont éventuellement des
messages à faire passer en effet cette
position conserver à vous décidez vous
décidez vous même ce que ce que vous
faites c'est une position que vous avez
donc demandé un pas de lien direct pas
de place effectivement dans
l'organigramme vous permet de survivre à
tous les changements cabinet et y en a
eu le temps d'être libre non mais de
survivre aux je cherche pas à survivre
dans suffit les mais oui il ya des
changements mais dans sa classe des
conseillers ouais mais c'est hollande ne
soyez pas surpris parce que la plupart
de ceux qui ont changé de fonction
ils ont pris une autre fonction parce
que ces sites c'est dans leur histoire
c'est dans leur parcours et c'est pas
surprenant françois l'on n'a pas un
cabinet est normal en 2012
quand il est arrivé il avait un cabinet
de 40 48 ou 49 personnes je crois que
sarkozy avait un cabinet de 60 ou 70
donc il a beaucoup réduit la toile et
dans cette
de ces personnes qui sont là c'est
normal qu'à un moment donné le fatigant
si pour certains moi je c'est pas grave
mais pour certains c'est sont ils sont
vraiment sur le c'est très dur pour
vient justement au début du quinquennat
françois hollande a mis longtemps à
endosser le costume de président de la
république
pourquoi selon vous voulez vous qu'ils
connaisseurs il est hélas il enfin moi
j'ai toujours pensé qu'il est allé plus
vite que ce que l'on a dit mais l'image
qui était la sienne a été celle que vous
venez de traduire
il a fait d'ailleurs une campagne
peut-être aussi l'erreur d'appréciation
sur la présidence normale alors ça
c'était un bon thème de campagne
mais une fois que vous êtes président
c'est une fois que j'ai président vous
vous n'êtes plus normal ou plutôt vous
rester normal mais votre fonction ne
l'est pas et donc ça m'a beaucoup marqué
ça l'est les français la présidence
normale c'était évidemment par
comparaison avec son prédécesseur
donc il en a beaucoup joué il a fait
même bruit longtemps quand même donc à
rentrer un peu dans la laure moi je
trouve pas non je trouve qu'il a été
assez vite et pour moi ça a commencé
j'ai envie de dire delmotte dès le mois
de septembre 2012 s'il était bien
installé quoi après bon parce que quand
il est élu en mai un prix y est les
législatives il ya les législatives avec
bon un peu de décompression quand même
pendant les vingt ans lui a reproché de
prendre des vacances
rendez compte à feu au mois d'août 2012
car tout le monde a oublié que sarkozy
en avait primé mais il est aller
pique-niquer avec george bush quand même
je moi je préférerais voir hollande à
brégançon que fait cliquer et george
bush a quand même avec vous cherchez une
part de travail aussi une part des scud
sur la guerre en irak que nous n'avions
pas accepté de faire
et
et donc il est allé assez je pense qu'au
mois de septembre il était dedans mais
la population ne le voyait c'est vrai je
pas contesté je voyais pas comme ça est
ce que vous vous trouvez qu'elle a
changé depuis l'italie je pense qu'il
est en gravité oui oui un démon et les
plus graves de ces pesant lalala l'est
il pratique toujours l'humour oui enfin
mon avis même il retient à à ce que je
pense qu'il pourrait en faire beaucoup
plus et avec mais bon le président la
république ne peux rien moi un point sur
lequel goudé soit peut-être de ne déçoit
pas mais j'ai toujours aimé les meetings
qu'il a fait pendant la campagne
et quand il était premier secrétaire du
parti social et quand il était candidat
encore elle c'était un bonheur ses
meetings
si j'ai un regret aujourd'hui en fait
c'est que j'aimerais le revoir en
meeting le président le président me
fais pas
vous conservez je crois bernard poignant
toutes les archives écrites tout les
noms alors je les fais jeux wii ge alors
je les fais oui je les fais jusqu'en
jusqu'au 15 mai 2012
d'accord tout ce qui avant j'ai récupéré
le plus que j'ai pu que vous aidez
transmettre quoi et en plus maintenant
après le 15 mai j'ai continué et j'ai
été je peux dire comme ça rappe a
rappelé à l'ordre mardi non depuis le 15
mai 2012 et l'investiture
tout doit aller aux archives d'état dont
ceux que j'avais gardé avant et qui
était à la fondation jean jaurès a fait
en fait il a fallu le rendre est ce que
vous allez en faire un livre
non mononc hijab ou les étoiles elles y
vont trouver justement c'est trop pas la
vraie et
et voilà puisque tout meilleurs les
livres sont à la mode c'est vrai vous
avez évoqué il ya un instant les
vacances à brégançon à l'époque françois
hollande était accompagné de sa compagne
valérie trierweiler l elysée vous a
demandé un peu de montées au créneau
lorsque le livre est sorti un merci pour
ce moment fait ce que vous craignez une
réplique de l'ancienne compagne du se
mêlera un tome 2 ou l'adaptation cinéma
non aujourd'hui je crois que je croquais
plus rien à craindre ce que voulait dire
décline au moral aussi
moi je pense que rien à craindre
non je pense que c'est klaus s'est clos
pour les français pourquoi pour les
français mais les auteurs n'ont pas pour
les auteurs c'est leur affaire
je pensais que ouais je pense que c'est
derrière nous et derrière lui très bien
merci
bayon vous remercie merci père yvon vous
remercie encore une fois c'est la
première fois que vous participez à une
émission de 45 minutes comme ça depuis
que vous conseiller françois hollande
votre ami de trente ans ça l'est mais
merci merci merci à vous pour soir à
tout ça très vite